I saw this wild news story it was about
about this guy Jesse Smollett and and
all of these and he was a Empire actor
who who um allegedly was attacked on the
streets of Chicago and it just seems
like a fake story and I think he's I
think this guy is black and white
actually he is a yeah he's mixed he
might be Middle Eastern mush for what
ethnicity is I mean he's at least part
uh I would say he has a little bit of an
Arabian look possibly but he's either
he's like probably mixed but um but this
[ __ ] just seems so fake it's ridiculous
man you know he was attacked they can't
find any video footage they've looked
apparently and a lot of this is a legend
it's it's it they've looked at a lot of
you know the police departments looked
at a lot of different tapes and just the
from different areas he was at a subway
it was below zero they threw bleach on
him they threw bleach on him and they
said that they they yelled racial stuff
and make America great again stuff it's
just in the thing that makes me a most
upset about this sort of deal is
look I'm not surprised at anything that
comes out of Hollywood you know I don't
believe half of these claims I don't
believe half of what I hear out here but
you know when you are when there's
already issues of race in America and
there's already people that really are
getting attacked by different
ethnicities because of their ethnicity
to do something like this is just too
much and it's not fair it just really
minimizes well it's just first of all
it's taking advantage of something
that's really Civ it's really it's
really selfish if you were using those
things to gain acclaim for yourself
because a lot of
you know a lot of trial and error has
gone into into like integration and
segregation and racial you know just
like you know America's slowly building
its way out of you know the tough spot
that it was in from slavery and you know
when you have you know when you have
somebody who's just kind of it just
minimizes all the I feel like the
advancement when you use these things
for your own value to try and get ahead
now I can do I think something could
have happened in this guy yeah he could
have fell outs he could have fell down
you know I don't know how they said he's
throwing it somebody threw a liquid on
him and it was like five it was like
five degrees or something so I don't
know who's running around with a liquid
chasing this young guy it just all
sounds crazy and they put a noose on his
neck dude I mean I just I mean come on
man
it just at a certain point if something
seems too unbelievable then it then it
you know it's just like that's where it
lands and so many black you know DD on
the news somebody black like youtubers
and news people have come out and said
this is ridiculous man you know so it's
nice to see that people aren't just
siding with their own race anymore that
people are starting to say okay well
this seems fake on this and this seems
fake on this and it doesn't matter who
you are because that's a place where I
think you know that's a great place to
be at because then we're all can be
moving forward you know we all can be
we're all judging each other based on
what's going on right now and it's I
think you know and I feel sorry for this
young man as to why he feels like he
needs to do this if he's trying to it
just seemed too much and then he put out
a video the other day or somebody did of
him he called himself the gay to POC
that he fought back and I don't know it
just
seems like somebody really taking
advantage of um you know a lot has gone
in and that meant a lot of people of
sacrifice their lives a lot of people
have you know done so much to get race
relations into a good place and in a lot
of America they are the only place
they're not really that great a lot of
times is in the news you know I hate the
fact that the news always just focuses
on you know just they'll you know
they'll find the one you know idiot
redneck or and they'll always focus on
that guy you know we're not redneck but
yeah just some racists you know real
perv doubt dude he's out there jerking
off on a little you know black statues
in his yard or something and they find
that dude and it's like man that's the
there's so few of that dude left I wish
they would sometimes focus on people who
you know we're that they wouldn't focus
on that but this just seems like I don't
know just waiting cool man it's just not
a cool thing to do there's other ways to
increase your you know your visibility
and something could have happened to
this man I think he could uh you know
III sickle could have hit him maybe a
hard cook you know it was snowing a
couple hard snowflakes could have taken
this dude down I mean he just copped a
subway sandwich they said and I don't
know if it was that meatball hit or what
it was but you know I mean it could have
been a turkey ad turkey now if he said
Jimmy John's I could see somebody
jumping his ass for a Jimmy John brother
those [ __ ] are good but ain't nobody
[ __ ] beaten you ass in the middle of
the night randomly like they tracked you
there nobody's tracking your ass daddy
nobody's ain't nobody beating nobody's
ass for a Subway sandwich now Jimmy
john-boy Camaro son [ __ ] even one of
those on what's that other one that
weird wooden that's kind of out now it's
so Jersey Mike's that [ __ ] taste taste
like your cousin [ __ ] spit on it at
the end but you know and it's all the
meats a little wet but even that I could
see somebody coming at your boy Fred
maybe and you know if they real hungry
but here's one I don't believe jealous
are but here's one don't believe Jesse
Smollett because ain't nobody
nobody whooping nobody's ass in zero
degree weather for a damn subway bro you
know that [ __ ] ain't nobody trying to
get nobody subway Sam winch on now that
Jimmy john-boy somebody running around
with a turkey tom with extra Turkey son
I'll [ __ ] it
you know I'll set a tripwire on the
sidewalk for that do you know [ __ ]
tase somebody for a damn you know for a
full length Jimmy john-boy I like them
Jimmy John's you feel me
I like that Jimmy John with him tomatoes
and then [ __ ] pickles on the lawn
baby you got me but come on bro get
right dude
and don't use you know all to use
something that that is that powerful
just for your own gain that's just
[ __ ] up bro it's real selfish so I
think they need to investigate this
guy's ego anybody whooping nobody's
asked for a damn subway bud you know and
the good thing is is that this guy is
multiracial so everybody should be
ashamed of this man behavior but then at
the same time we've all done [ __ ] so you
know I can understand how your ego can
get out of control and you could do
things but this is a little bit much
when you're using things like that that
are that important because what if
somebody now goes on the street and they
go attack somebody because you did this
they get you know some crazed Empire fan
or something and I've never even heard
of this guy so and maybe he had maybe
had enough people hadn't heard of him
and that's why he's doing this in the
first place but it's just uh it's not
nice man and it's selfish that's what I
think now I could be wrong but you know
in [ __ ] I could be wrong and if I am
wrong man I'm you know I mean I don't
know this guy he don't know me but if
I'm wrong then yeah I'm I'm sorry but
but it just feels real [ __ ] fake bro
somebody beat nobody's asked for a damn
subway anyway good evening good
afternoon and other times thanks for
watching that video you just saw I mean
it was okay but the next video you can
watch could be way better
what if you watch a video right now that
changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one watch this one watch
this one watches one